So a lot of people write in and ask how
the WHY relates to
the vision or mission of your company.
The WHY is like the
foundation of your house.
It's there and it gives everything above it
solidity.
So my WHY is to inspire people to
do the things that inspire them so
together each of us can
change our world for the better.
That's why I get out of bed in the morning,
that's what inspires me.
I look for stories like that.
Now the WHY is not always good
for public consumption
because sometimes the words
are clunky. Mine is a little bit clunky.
And so the way you think about a vision
is if my WHY were to come to life,
if 20, 30, 40, 50 years from now everything went
perfectly and I were able to live my WHY
and bring it to life in perfect form,
what would the world look like?
That's why we call it vision
because you can see it.
My vision is to create a world in which
the vast majority of people wake
up every single morning inspired,
feel safe at work and return home fulfilled
at the end of the day.
That's my vision. That's the thing that I see in the
future that I want to build.
My mission is to commit all of my talents and all
of my energies to build that world.
So I speak, I write, I teach, anything that I
can do, I advise, any kind of anything I can do.
I look for ideas that help
advance my vision.
So my mission are things that I will do to help advance
the vision that I have
that was all set in motion
as soon as I learned my WHY.